the deed you smell a hundred la Salaam
alaikum peace be with you welcome to
another episode of the D show my next
guest coming in all the way from New
York you might know him from a starring
role and where is that woman to veil or
not to veil Mohammed Asha Wally here on
the Dean show to cover tver that's the
question that we're asking it today to
veil or not to vail you decide here on
the Dean show will be right back this is
the DG this is the days is the danger
this is the days is the theme jus this
is the thing is the thing
this is the this is welcome back to the
Dean show Sheikh Mohammed as Chanelle we
how are you like a lil 800 lesbian all
the way from New York the Big Apple here
in the Windy City first time pretty much
yeah so I introduced you as the person
who had the starring role in where's
that woman and from vail or not to vail
and that's the question we know that you
know in the show we really talk about
serious topics purpose of life why
you've been created where you going when
you die def is a reality even though you
want to ignore it sleep on it but it's
something that you should really take
seriously and then when we investigate
we come to know that there is a purpose
in life and it comes from the crater not
from just you know us conjuring things
up and just you know as you go make it
up based on proof knowing that is the
truth and from there we try our humble
best to submit to all the beautiful
injunctions that the craters told us do
because it's wrong good everything that
creators told us to do it's good for us
one of these things is a lot of
misconceptions about but many of the
women when they come to this realization
that God knows best I want to please him
and they start to establish the prayer
five times a day only worshiping God
giving in charity being the best in
character and the modest way of dress
not only for the man before the woman
too we come to this issue of the veil so
you are known for that starring role the
starring lecture that you covered to
veil or not to veil and we want to talk
about this and at the end we really want
to encourage people to go we're going to
have it at the Dean show calm people
could download it and share it with
their families their friends what made
you do this build or not Sofia what made
you come up with this and what was the
motivating factor behind this smelly
rahman al rahim alhamdu lillahi rabbil
aalameen sort of cilantro dark metal you
are I mean or do savage marine we begin
first in the name of Allah the most
merciful the bus tour of mercy all
praise due to Allah Almighty God Lord of
the Worlds and may the peace and
blessings of Allah be upon his final
messenger muhammad Hooley sent as a
mercy to the world's me honestly
it was a whole bombardment of issues
mostly many of our sisters for one
reason or another who felt disinterested
or chased away or perhaps undesired from
putting this hedge a bond especially in
these times and even more so in the
likes of these cultures that was
probably at people they're very close to
me very dear to my heart that I wish
they could have an inside scope as to
the implications of hey Jeb and not
wearing hijab and what it means to them
and what kind of honor it is for them I
felt like I was fundamental for them to
know why do you think why is it so
important that you know in today's
society it's like show more and you'll
get more you get a higher pay maybe
higher position you know you'll be worth
more than you know the skirts keep going
up even in our country here where if you
go back so far the women were instead of
having the sleeves up to here they were
down here and then here the more you go
back and now the skirts they went down
from covering the ankles to now all the
way above the knee having girls just
even I'm she's real uncomfortable she's
trying to pull it down but it's like you
won't get that anchor position you might
not even fit in you're not cool right
you're old-fashioned now the more modest
that you carry yourself the more
modestly you carry so why do you think
this is well first of all this is an
established fact just to further back
what you're saying even some
sociologists have put out statistics
that a woman has a fourteen percent
chance a better chance at getting hired
depending on how more provocatively
she's dressed unlike you said the reason
being is because it's the fashion
nowadays it's the culture we're in an
age unfortunately of moral decay and a
sad dismal slippery slope and that's why
one of the important issues to
understand is that it that he jab is not
a matter of fashion and it's not a
matter of culture thus it's not bound to
time in place rather is something that
our sisters should be proud of and all
this is a divine ordinance there is
something that comes from Allah the most
high who knows what has happened and
what
happen and what didn't happen how did it
happened how it would have happened
these things are all the same so Allah
subhana Allah and I'm sure and I've
asked sisters that many of them they
don't put hey Jeb on why because they
believe its culture so why would I wear
something that belongs to an old culture
or an outside culture when I'm part of
this culture and this is a good argument
had hey Jeb in culture but the issue of
hijab those that claim that it's
unfounded in Islam and it's a tradition
these people simply have not opened up
or an explicit in the Book of Allah
soprano Tyler prep is not the time and
place to expand on that they can perhaps
go back to that lecture sorta no Luther
hey Jeb abundant resources can tell you
this is a matter of complete agreement
unanimously between the Muslims this is
a command from the Lord of the world for
the honor and the betterment of our
sisters right and once again I'm sure
that they think its culture and all of
the proofs of that is that many of our
sisters have different definitions as to
what hey Jeb is why because they took it
from their surrounding environments not
from the book of allah and the Sunnah of
the best of examples our prophet
muhammad salallahu name so much so what
is the proper concept of hijab weight
loss of panama tada the exultant of the
height he says insulting or and tell the
believing women to lower their gaze and
guard their chastity after telling the
men to do it in verse before many
continues and saying and let them drape
their coverings over their bosoms means
supposed to start from above the bosom
right and Drake below it's not an issue
of hair it's not an issue of just the
neck rather its report did you check the
interpretations we can fit in others
that this was already known to the
people in the pre-islamic period right
they used to do these things but hey Jeb
is for to begin there and to conceal the
entire body to conceal what is naturally
different about the woman's body and
what is unique and what is more inviting
to the opposite gender so tuhan cover an
entire body whereas it is not seen nor
is the garment that she wears tight so
it shows the shape nor the see-through
so it shows the skin behind it this in
general is the the guideline for his jab
and the protocol for a Muslim woman that
wants to go now if someone from the
outside looking in or even some Muslims
who
say they look at this is something
cultural or okay now they say that the
argument this is something demeaning to
him why would God if he wanted this
hijab is not there it's not it doesn't
say hijab and what you're saying is this
something old-fashioned that you're
trying to just put this woman behind a
veil you're demeaning her you're putting
her down we're in a modern age brother
if adding clothes so a woman is
demeaning then the woman that is saying
that has also been denigrated because
she's wearing clothes as well right
mm-hmm but if she says I changed the way
I was initially created a baby I was
naked I put clothes on for modesty then
we say our sisters have more modesty
right and actually the Koran says the
exact opposite the Quran in the
versatile I said that I alluded to
before it mentions that veluka Edna you
are often a fillet with vain this hijab
ordinance is so there will be more
likely they may be recognized it's not
to curb the woman is for her to be
recognized that I'm a free respectable
individual that does not succumb to the
conformity of society there are a result
of trial and error between generations
where they decide something and then
repeal it the next day and the likes no
this for her to be recognized I am
something different as the prophets of
Allah Allah said in height and so I
Muslim foretold by la baraja glad
tidings to the strangers this for her to
be put on a pedestal for her honour
prestige and her intellect I heard you
mentioned something about the people you
were quoting somebody saying that the
people who say that this is not in the
Quran what was your response to that is
explicit it's a certain note yeah the
fourth chapter of the Quran and so that
I said the 33rd chapter of the Quran in
more than one and two and three verses
so those people i know i heard someone
saying that they're not picking up the
crown even reading the quran because if
they read it then they would see that
it's there they're banking on ignorance
you know many times we say and it's in
that book why because we know that we're
in age of youtube junkies and Facebook
fanatics analyze when people don't read
anymore it's not has come a long time
ago you go into a train station you find
everyone with a book in his hand now
everyone has their iPad and they're
watching a video or a music video or a
clip or reading some sports reviews
that's it but reading meaningful content
this is an endangered species nowadays
don't we see remnants of this also in
the Bible absolutely it's mentioned that
it is shameful for a woman to show her
hair perhaps in the church it was
mentioned one reference and it's the
Bible now this is the Christian
scripture and the Jewish absolutely and
I know Christian women that cover their
hair religious committed Baptist elderly
woman friends of mine that I went to
school with they would explain this to
me I didn't learn this from Islamic
services or some will go actually with
you know the high skirts and the tawdry
dress into the trip but they'll put a
little bit something on the hair here's
it because they know something is
supposed to be something that perhaps
they're hoping that this is sufficient
this is like going far away from the
organic way the organic way is
worshipping God alone people resorted to
worship in the creation of God Islam is
calling you to that which is organic
which is good which is pure pure
monotheism and everything that's good
good character good manners modesty
that's a part of your your faith isn't
it absolutely the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said indeed
what has remained among the people from
the words of the very first prophethood
meaning this was taught by all the
prophets Jesus and Moses and Abraham and
Noah peace and blessings be upon them
all this statement who has remained what
is it if you do not have modesty than do
a jewish meaning case closed it's done
after that modesty that's the hey john
mahdessian a man are two twins he said
some of our audio sometimes narrated by
hacking and one of them is lifted the
other goes with it yeah that's talk that
speech that's action that's dress
modesty and to veil or not to veil it's
out there at the Dean show calm you can
watch it we're talking about it we'll be
right back with more in charlotte here
on the Dean show easy when outside
everything looks good you see the
hundred-thousand-dollar cars you see a
lot of diamonds you see a lot of females
and they think that this is you know
this is the life this is this is like no
paradise right here
with this my job to go into someone's
hard to change their heart your job is
to topi what the truth is and the ally
of it is while we're sitting here while
i'm sitting here constantly paying for
the disease to cure was free you think
these things are going to bring you
happiness you know why you keep going
back to the club and you keep going back
to these desires because you never find
satisfaction it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain think you're happy you're
kidding you're sitting is really all you
what we are offering in Islam what we
have found in Islam for ourselves is a
means by which our hearts are in peace
they're at rest they're not discontent
we are pleased with what we have
gah
back here on a Dean show we're
discussing to veil or not to vail you
put it together we want to get it out
there to the world so people can
download it you mine they can share it
absolutely because look man we care so
that's why we share hundred and that's
why we're here with you on the Dean show
and I'm telling you anyone who takes the
time to investigate this way of life
this way of life of all the messages of
God Jesus lived it he was a Muslim he
submitted to the will of God Moses
Abraham and the last and final master
Muhammad peace be upon him they all live
this way of life were we're humbly
trying to live do we have life from the
crater it's not man-made organized by
man or men is organized by the one who
created man in mention am I telling the
truth how so amen so we're talking about
modesty people who dig deep they look
into Islam your character gets better
and you stop using that filth that you
might have used your dress gets better
so many people start smelling better huh
and you start feeling better you start
feeling good but the pop culture people
are emulating the superstars who are not
dressing modestly and not setting a good
example so people tend to follow them
instead of following the best of
examples and they start to unveil why do
you think this is talk to us there's
actually an excellent research and
researcher professor Eileen zur Bregan
from the University of California she's
a psychologist I've been following her
literature for years now she has a book
under print called the sexualization of
girls and girls what's her name again
Eileen's air Bregan ok she's a
psychologist University of California
she talks about how from a very young
age in this culture girls are bombarded
with a certain style of media and
fashion and brainwashing tinkerbell in
her miniskirt right and then Little
Mermaid a fish on the bottom and nothing
on top right yeah uh Hannah Montana and
the likes this instills in the girls
through the magazines and through the
cartoons it through the Barbie a sense
of incompetents when they grow up if
they can
be attractive according to today's
definition of attractive and catch the
attention of men and then when they grow
up and they can't do it that's their
grading and I say time and time again if
Islam supposedly oppressed women even
though if you ask our sisters they'll
tell you we want to put the hedge elbow
right our Father didn't make us do it
but let's say they were oppressed what
is worse or pressing her mind or
oppressing her body mm-hmm or pressing
her mind in the sense that when they
grow and they feel incompetent because
she can't turn heads you have not anemia
they stop eating then the psychological
disorders and any man bulimia and the
likes this is all you know physical that
weekend looks like illogical it's a
disaster and it's something we're living
nowadays you know the industries and the
money invested in the likes of these
effort is profound it's greater than all
the sports industries combined they're
using a woman as a commodity she's a sex
object it's that simple just saw a
billboard the other day I mean they had
something for you know selling oil or
something for a car and they had like
when we stock for law you have a woman
why is she up there for oil because if
you put a guy up there and I'm gonna
sell your oil yeah you know they know
that woman is unique and we say we are
acknowledging the woman's beauty and
that's why it is not to be a free
distribution in the streets nor does she
feel worthy only when she catches a wish
a whistle from someone her beauty is
more than that it's her physical we
acknowledge and it's even beyond that
it's at heart and in her mind and she's
more than just a piece of flesh I'm not
talking about cooking oil I'm to my car
oil it's disgusting what they've done to
our our mothers our sisters and Islam
God wants the best that's why he sent us
the guidance so when we go away from it
we got trouble don't we so when you have
your children they're watching you
mentioned Timmy tam was this Baker what
was it the names Myra Cyrus with some of
these things that we think are innocent
but they're getting programmed should
the parents stay away from letting their
kids watch some of these things they're
even on the Disney Channel but now at
the end these young girls are coming up
and now they're taking it all off there
on stage singing you know in a tawdry
dress and now the children have been
watching them since youth
this is very important to not allow our
measuring system be our and pg-13 and G
because this is not our system of
measuring and even there's it's unstable
it changes what was PG 13 years ago is G
now and what was our a long time ago is
pg-13 borderline now this is the system
that I was not set by Allah Subhan Allah
Tala not doesn't take into consideration
what's best I think the consideration
was going to make money not what's best
for humanity and that's why we tell the
people that of the greatest tricks of
Shaitaan and there are humans that are
employed by faith on because it serves
their momentary worldly interests of the
tricks of Shaitaan is to name things
right the gratings on movies and the
likes with other than their name right
he went to add them peace and blessings
be upon him and he said shall I not
invite you to the tree of eternal life
was a disaster and in a kingdom that
will never perish nowadays same thing
adultery is called what they're making
love right intoxication is what a cold
drink mm-hm and this is a long list of
satanic mechanisms it is used disney
know we have quran and sunnah and we
raise our head high thanking allah for
that blessing that is a beautiful busty
paradise at the end you obey the one who
created you obey the boss you get paid
you expect a bit paid you can put your
hand out I'm you don't even show up to
work you don't do the job I mean you're
still a little bit timid you won't even
put your hand out you know to ask for a
paycheck how could we expect to get
we're going to die is that a fact we
can't argue about that everyone knows
that so even our brothers in humanity
who are not yet Muslim that everyone has
the potential to submit to God that's
all we're Thomas submitting to God and
obeying God based on true proofs and
evidences we're not blinding Islam
calling you to blindly follow something
no our logic and our reason directs us
to realize that this is the message from
the one true God that has been
unadulterated perfect for every walk of
life right upon realizing that we say we
trusted fully so if anyone is a skeptic
now but he looks at the verbatim word of
God the Quran will he come to the
conclusion be sincere looking for the
truth that this is from the crater it's
not some man writing it from 14
centuries ago or men a collaboration of
man well they come to that
the age of the Quran itself says the
Quran tells us don't you reflect on the
Quran if it was from other than Allah
you would have found many discrepancies
in it the Quran says don't you reason
don't you think don't you look it's
asking you to call upon that blessing
that God differentiated between you and
the animals with reason so reason even
the Bible says come let us reason
together and it makes sense because I'm
sure even if you're our guest today and
you're tuning in you bumped into us by
accident you like you know the moral
decay of society and you seeing things
that even you you're not falling trapped
to victim to you don't like it and you
see that we're talking about this is
something good organic wholesome modesty
and God has called us to be modest
absolutely so before we go to a break
tell us now to veil or not to veil get
it we're just discussing some of the
things that you discussed in it and you
can get this at the Dean show calm
you'll have your own private section
there people go and download share it
with the world what are some 11 op still
want to go many that some of our Muslim
sisters have in wearing the most and
sisters may Allah preserve them and
empower them and increase them in
guidance upon their guidance they deal
with lots of obstacles some are more
legitimate than others some you can
categorize them maybe as excuses but
definitely the family issue right it's
not easy to go against the tide and this
is legitimate this must be recognized
family's family issues let's hold off
their the signal we got to go to break
we're going to continue on from there
some of these excuses challenges family
will start off with that obstacle that
challenge when we come back here on the
Dean show
I am not afraid to stand alone if allies
by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
allies by my side I am not afraid to
stay alone I am not afraid to stand
alone if Eliza I am Not Afraid
back here on the Dean show tuve
or not to vail you gotta listen to this
lecture my guest here by the grace of
the creditor happens in our put it
together I've hummed allow me to create
a reward you me too i want to get reward
i want to get the agenda and that's what
we should be striving for shouldn't we
we know this life is transitory is short
we're going to die let's be the best at
whatever profession that we are in
currently but if we just put all of our
chips in this basket at the end we're
going to die but what's aslam calling us
to do isn't it i mean shouldn't we
showed our hopes and aspirations to
something that's eternal is forever
agenda paradise avoiding the Hellfire
had the smart thing to do absolutely you
mentioned it that we work for the
ultimate goal paradise and Islam
actually calls us to a paradise were in
there exists what the i has never seen
the air has never heard with never
dawned upon the imagination of a human
being as our Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon demands would confirm
that he informed us also it invites us
even before that to enjoy and live the
goodly life a life when you're happy a
life when you're safe life when you're
prosperous and successful a life
worrying humanity is working for the
betterment of themselves right and this
is what's pleasing to the Creator
amazing tell us now okay we had a live
sit down session someone that you can
get some perspective from a sister so we
left off with family obstacles sometimes
law will test you through your fat you
love your mother and father but now
they're the ones they're Muslim to maybe
Cat Cat they've caught the culture clash
right so now they think he's not a job
is some cultural thing and they're
scared they say may look you're going to
end up Six Feet Under if you wear these
people are it's llama phobia it's crazy
so they say no we're going to disown you
if you do they give you a hard time you
sat with a sister who we love our
sisters and we're not being judgmental
we just want the best form because we
care so tell us how did this go and what
advice do you give for sisters who are
having that obstacle in their way well
as you mentioned is very important for
the Muslim to get past any obstacle in
his life is to remember that this life
is transitory its temporal and at the
same time that our ultimate goal is para
and our Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him who we believe him
with our eyes closed he informed us that
paradise is surrounded with difficulties
with hardship so that's one you know
keep our eyes on the prize and we move
forward confident that Allah will not
allow our efforts to go to waste and
that if we try he will empower us by his
permission if we seek the means we will
arrive at our desired destination the
second issue is very important our
systems need to remember that they owe
it to their parents for example to
lighten their load on the day of
judgment their parents perhaps did not
adopt or learn or perhaps dismiss this
aspect of Islam so if you love your
parents and you truly want to be kind to
your parents lighten the load that they
have to carry on their shoulders on the
day of judgment by disobeying them and
that it was a beautiful word that I
heard him say Horomia rahim allah that
was of the manifestations of his you
know his scholarly nature may allah have
mercy on him someone came home and says
what he said it's lamb tells me to be
kind to my parents so the person is not
wear hijab came to this great scholar
and said Islam says be good to my
parents but my parents saying don't wear
hijab or what do I do so everyone knows
the ruling you don't disobey the Creator
for the sake of the creation
irrespective who they are who do you owe
more to but his words were brilliant he
said it is out of kindness to your
parents that you disobey them in this
because you're helping them attain
salvation a day of judgment when there's
questioning and this was something
remarkable and I try always to relate to
my sisters hoping that they can find a
fuel tank in those words by Allah's
permission to climb out of their their
dilemma one scholar that we had as a
person of knowledge this issue came up
about parents and the personal knowledge
he flipped he said look man be real with
yourself if you wanted a fornicate if
you wanted to do drug you you wouldn't
be asking your parents you'd be going to
do it if it was for that sin but now the
good you're using your parents is this
you can this sometimes be something yeah
obviously the parents you know this
might be holding you back but sometimes
do we use these things as a scapegoat
sometimes at times and
uh I know that this is a conversation
that me and you have a great passion for
that perhaps it would lead to many many
stories yeah but I want to once again
reiterate to my sisters that you owe it
number one to your parents right number
two you owe it to your sisters that they
want to do what you want to do so
everyone's waiting for someone to be the
first brick be that first brick and get
the rewards for everyone after you write
be that strong person be that person
that is a role model that is so scarce
nowadays you owe it to the brothers as
well that are having difficulty lowering
their gaze and the likes don't be a
reason for them to take glance after
glance and have their hearts black and
distance them from Allah don't accept
for yourself to be a tool for Shaitaan
like the others you're different you're
not like everybody else you're someone
that Allah chose with the gift of Islam
so be grateful for that gifts Allah can
keep that gift for you hmm and keep it
there safe and sound to the day that you
meet him we have some of our brothers
all of us we made mistakes may Allah
forgive us who ran off and they've you
know got married or the sister ran off
and got married didn't get the parents
permission just still kind of wrapping
this up with the parents but now you
know they're they're worried about this
so may Allah make itself in their heart
the day they can do it so you know kind
of look back and when you want that when
you have that drive in you to want to
please Allah skier sincere allow what
will give you the strength to do in the
courage is that true and absolutely
absolutely the person that wants to find
an excuse will find an excuse y and the
one that wants to please Allah Allah is
too merciful to leave them hanging drive
ya back to this before we wrap it up
what other from the sisters perspective
perspective side did this is to give you
from other sisters who are out there
that we can help you know soften their
hearts and get their perspective on the
issue some of these some of the
obstacles as we said some have more
legitimacy than others of the good
responses that lower water sisters for
their answers they said the issue of it
being uncomfortable choking other likes
I mean this is a very miss the argument
that I'm not sure they're convinced up
to begin with perhaps it's not worth the
time but of it is the harshness
the brothers and I remind our brothers
time and time again of the height of the
prophet salallahu artists and that allah
is gentle and he loves gentleness feel
Emily coolly in all matters this was
narrated by Ahmed and he said Sal Allahu
Allah Salem and indeed Allah grants on
the basis of gentleness what is not
grant on the basis of harshness so don't
you dare be an obstacle right for not
being patient or approaching the wrong
way or talking down to them our sisters
many of them they don't know Jeb is part
of Islam I thought of some culture many
of them we assume don't love Allah and
His Messenger even if they know it's
from Islam that doesn't mean they're
enemies to the Dean no we have to
encourage them and push them and carry
them along and be grateful that Allah
guided us so we want to you know move
that guidance beyond ourselves in
Bukhari and Muslim the man that used to
drink wine when the punishment was
carried out on him a man cursing said
don't curse him he's a sinner a major
sin he said before I know that he loves
Alana's messenger who's our sisters are
more often not fall into this category
as well so we were to wish the good for
them and pray for that can be gentle and
patient time and time again in effort
that they will be in our scale of good
deeds and they love preserve them
wherever they are and keep them strong
and keep them steadfast upon this Dean
we have like a minute left we're almost
out of time when is one we got to
address this also some of the sip stirs
we've seen this as an obstacle they'll
see sisters or sisters who are wearing a
veil on their head but everything else
is exposed out there real ties Jordache
jeans everything is just you know the
figure is just totally out there for the
we'll see but they got something on your
head is this a job go back to the veil
or not today today or not the whale okay
so we have so much we had so much to
cover obviously so little time to veil
or not to vail people get it at your
private sex is dean show calm your go
into detail on these things and she'll
go to a certain degree last closing
comments and suggestions advice just
like a local you read to me a quote that
I hope in shower laws that our viewers
can benefit from as well for a famous
boxer Oh we'll get that yeah and the
clothing was something amazing for me to
hear ya hum didn't I so ok well thank
you very much we're gonna give people to
do vale or not to vail look it up at the
didn't show calm we look forward to
having
you hear back on the Dean show get low
fee so frequent thank you very much
welcome I love war Japan thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Dean
shot an outside of the love that we give
this advice and we hope that you got to
benefit we're going to finish up we want
to get your your stories also those
sisters who've overcome some of these
challenges you know write to us at the
Dean show calm we also have many people
that help us you know maintained his
facebook page our volunteers will get it
to us send it posted there we want to
end off with a beautiful call you guys
know Muhammad Ali he accepted his
beautiful way of value for slam as many
R's the fastest-growing way of life in
the world today and he SAT his his
beloved his daughter on his lap and she
narrates the story from her father
saying that you know he SAT me down and
he looked me straight in the eyes and he
said Hannah that's his daughter
everything that God made valuable in the
world is covered and hard to get to he
said to his daughter Muhammad Ali is
saying where are diamonds deep down in
the ground covered and protected where
do you find Pearl's he says to his
daughter deep down at the bottom of the
ocean covered up and protected in a
beautiful show he continued I was
talking to a daughter he said where do
you find gold he said way down in the
mine covered over the layers and layers
of rock you've got to work hard to get
them he continued hard say she said he
looked me with seriousness of eyes so
your body is sacred you're far more
precious than diamonds and pearls and
you should be covered too this is from
Muhammad Ali and I hope that you get to
benefit from this know that the crater
loves you the most more than your
parents more in this whole world and
everything combined so you want to work
to please your credit before you meet
your Creator so you could get his
pleasure and get his paradise and avoid
the Hellfire we'll see you next time
here in Charlotte the Dean show make
sure to pick up also the new dunya to
Dean we got the dvds for dawa share this
message of peace with the world you can
call us at one eight hundred sixes to
Islam operators standing by if you want
to accept if you want to gain peace in
life if you're one of our brothers and
humanity this is tuning in for the first
time and you want to submit to the one
guy the same guy to Jesus submitted to
call us right now 1 862 Islam until next
peace be with you this is the page ooh
this is the pain